io posso ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo episodio di a night to home
quell'oro un po strani noma bello come
visione
100 yen li ho trovati adesso per terra
va beh magari di tutti alla città
ragazze tutta la città di non trovarmi
devo trovare i soldi per terra ho finito
di cemento sei anni madonna enorme stato
come faccio a 2.000 euro che questo due
ore e cinquanta però vabbè o forse devo
seguire questo rumore qua perché c'era
questo nome come prima
pazzesco che cosa sei core l'umore vuol
dire che sono vicino però dotate come
ricorsi
arrivati a me rivasi america latina sono
persone
arrivederci e stato bello
trovati di solda ccd o tutti siamo in
panico
dove la zia
o noto
dove che ti ho mica buttata via subito
lanciata dalla finestra
va bè ragazzi abbiamo tutto dovevo solo
tornare all'autobus che adesso abbiamo i
soldi per pagarlo noi giusto mi sembra
ovviamente perché mai dovresti prendere
un autobus di secondo momento
[Applauso]
ma ce l'ho ce l'ho adesso inciampata
nell'autobus mi sembra corretto come
torino i soldi qua
come 400 neo come no come 300 moria la
pacifica e qua con l'amato ma va a
cagare
cominciava non potevi calcolare meli
subito yes
adesso aspettiamo il nostro bus ma ne
sono
abbiamo preso l'autobus
mi sono teletrasporta
non potevi stare con l'autista
dell'autobus che in questo caso mi
sembrava abbastanza safe visto tavolo
delle offerte già fatto praticato nei
400m che c'è perché offerte voce uscita
vado a casa
prendo tamoni questa il treno non lo
sapevo nella personale io mi dico perché
basta non in panico subito
dice k
minchiate volta a posto
devo resistere finché non passa il treno
con le parole
grazie dello schiaffo comunque è quanto
ci metto il suo treno passare se posso
chiedere un ora e mezza e non posso
passare lo stesso
[Musica]
i ragazzi è stata la cosa più brutta che
io abbia mai fatto nella mia vita
scavalca forti the network o demonio
truffa riguarda
non posso andare avanti non possa dare
indietro che cacchio devo fà corri e
basta
ma mi sono incazzato nata dentro
oddio è stato un jobs che l'orribile
ragazzi è passato il treno
la donna sta arrivando alla gente
sarebbe ad esempio ti prego le passate
passate cosa tranne apri apri grazie
arrivederci e stato orribile mi sono
cagato addosso
il treno è passato davanti tutto a posto
al master
a sono quasi arrivato a casa fantasma e
meno male che ho incontrato un sacco di
gente nel mettere sotto la targa
doveva dove dovrebbe essere casa mia 35
che ne so se il tipo salgo la scala
random e vedo se trovo casa mia tipo
così
is my home food io non lo so
ha corso anche share
ma sto male
aspetta aspettavo cos'è sto punto
interrogativo aspettato la ragazza che
io era il billing 35 e questo e 41
quindi siamo qua
sentivo di fronte questo è però non so
il piano il secondo
poi penso io l'ho provata ero troppo
contento è questa devo o il secondo e
quarto ragazzo non sa effettivamente a
partire da dove
ha posto tra non so non ho apposto
ciancio faccio una casa è finita è
finita è finita meno male che sono
arrivato a casa che allegra meno male
sono un po stanca sono arrivato a piedi
un casino per ok ho trovato che sono
fatto trovare casa mia da oggi ci ho
messo due ore però ok vado a dormire che
sono stanco c'è un tocco sul letto me ne
sbatto
mamma
perché non torni mi sento da sola
sapendo la specie di
coscienza che parla senza sapere un po
da solo effettivamente lo sono
mamma mamma non penso che il brano sia
tua mamma
il fatto che non c'è neanche una persona
nel mondo c'è neanche in silent hill ho
visto roba questi non c'è nessuno c'è
solo quella roba cristiana enorme e
basta siamo qua macchina dormita magari
torna domani mattina che te frega è
avanti
tanto non c'era mica gente brutta in
giro vieni vieni pure
e ho capito e non si apre la porta
e la mia stanza guardo entrata e la
porta si apre lentamente mamma sei tu il
tuo braccio sei ferito sei ferita cosa
resisti riprenderò cura di te hai la
mamma la mamma esce dalla stanza e
quindi sotto la vinto è tornata alla
mamma non so come già nessuno nel mondo
ma la mamma
o santo di dio ho guardato il braccio ed
effettivamente quella tipa grossa un
paio della ha preso è
però non pensavo avesse fatto così male
tutto ok
grazie mamma
facilmente mothers love l'amore della
mamma
ma bellissimo c'è bellissimo farà un po
toccante comunque
significativo che non mi aspettavo
e mi mettono al gatto nei titoli di coda
10 su 10 g n belli bravi bravi bello se
l'avrei mai detto un finale così
speziale speziate con le spezie ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto questa era the
night web o stati due episodi molto in
queste cose mi è piaciuto questo mi
piace fare di sapere cosa ne pensate a
questo punto nei commenti e non ci diamo
come sempre da ragazzi
[Musica]
ma